what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down where I have guests from
all walks of life
um and today we have a special guest um
we have the transformed wife on Twitter
welcome to the show
hi I don't know do you do you use your
full name on the Internet or no I know
some people
oh yeah
Lori Alexander okay it was I wasn't sure
I know some people yeah I know I'm not I
don't talk about Incognito okay uh
welcome welcome to I didn't want to be
the one you know welcome to the show
Lori
um so I was I was just talking to you
before and I was saying you're one of
the few women that teaches true I think
okay I'm gonna give a disclaimer to the
audience I I'm not I don't know the
Bible through and through
but I do think we have like an innate
ability to like sense something that is
true on some level and when I listen to
your stuff it sounds like you're one of
the few people that teach true biblical
submission
there are a few that do
okay God specific though in his word
it's supposed to be the aged women that
means the ones who have been married a
long time who have raised their children
who have been through the trials and the
tribulations and the suffering because
all marriages go through that and nobody
is to actually stay committed in a
marriage for many many years and like
for me it took a long time to actually
learn what submission was because in our
rebellious nature we want to rule over
our husbands we want to be in control
you see it you see it everywhere we want
to be in control and so that's why God
wants the older women to teach the young
women in the King James it says to obey
to be obedient to their husbands and it
also says in all the versions that Sarah
obeyed Abraham and we're her daughters
if we lose likewise but it's all
throughout from the very beginning of
time that we were created for our
husbands for their help meet God has an
authority structure
our culture was so much better when men
ran America you know but then women were
unhappy with the way men were running it
they thought they knew better so they
fought for the vote even though a small
tiny minority wanted the vote they
wanted to be at home taking they were
busy at home taking care of their
families and children and they had no
desire to be in politics and how the
vote they wanted their men's to take
care of that but the small little small
little group of suffragettes fought for
it got it because they knew better and
now women
overwhelmingly vote Democrat for
abortion the last three horrible
Democrat presidents I so few men they've
even been good presidents really because
if you even look back at some of the
things that Reagan did
um I think president Trump was probably
the best president in my lifetime and I
think he was so hated because he is very
masculine and he's a fighter but he does
say really stupid stuff you know really
stupid stuff
but anyway I don't want to really get
into Politics on this but anyway women
the whole point was that women want to
rule because they think they know better
but in Isaiah it says that women and
women will over them they destroy the
past you know because they just they
vote with their emotions and our
feelings we are very emotionally LED and
men are more logically glad
so you don't you know even on Twitter
you probably don't see men fighting you
as much as the women right
I've I've been attacked you know they
always say we're all afraid of men right
I've only been attacked like I had a
girl threatened to punch me once you
know what I'm like that's never happened
to me by a man all these women are
afraid of men I'm like I'm afraid of you
guys and one time my son when he was a
freshman in high school on the
basketball team he played the best
female basketball player probably in the
nation at that time I forget her name
she was a senior so he played their
varsity team and she was he had to guard
her he said he's never play and he
played his whole life had ever played
against any guys the first time he'd
ever played against girls she was so
nasty to him the things she was saying
to him and everything just we're
appalling just appalling
yeah yeah well and that's the thing like
they act like we're all sweet and
innocent but I'm like I am not afraid of
the Met like even if you say something
that men would not like and feminists do
it all the time they'll say matter trash
men are this men are That You Don't See
men attacking the women saying that I
know yeah we get attacked viciously
um I wanted to go back to something you
said in the beginning you said women
always want to rule over men
they have a rebellious nature uh tell me
about that well in in Genesis 3 16 it
says um a woman's desire will be for her
husband but he will rule over her and
that means the desire isn't for loving
and that wouldn't be a result of the
Fall it was a desire to rule over him
and that's why we have Bible verses
about contentual contentious and
quarreling women in the Bible and that a
foolish woman woman tears down her house
with her own hands so we have a lot of
responsibility of building up our
husbands or tearing them down building
up our homes and tearing them down
so and we just have a desire to control
I tried controlling my husband for 20
years and it didn't work
he he's not a pansy though he didn't
just like he tried to
you know everyone he every count man
godly man he talked to about me because
I was so with them they say oh just love
her more just love her more you know but
when he finally did start standing up to
me and saying no I'm gonna go play golf
Lori I don't care what you say
um but then I read a book that she
spanked me and I realized that
I was not being the wife that God called
me to be I was not supposed to try to
control my husband because that just
builds a huge wall between us and our
marriage just got worse and worse so
when I started just loving him and
accepting him and not controlling him at
all would you hate someone trying to
control you all the time
man will
depower they'll just try to control us
all the time like they do say that but
I don't think some men do but I don't
think most men have that in their nature
as much as women wanting to control men
they do want to lead their families and
make the decisions
um some of them there are some men who
women will write me he never wants to be
the leader you know how I do it I said
well
if he wants to go out to dinner ask him
where he wants to go start you know
letting him just make the decisions but
um we think we know best we really do we
really think like just like the supper
gets they thought they knew better
how to lead and guide this nation than
the men were doing
and look where we're at now
it's the women who are doing all into
the transgender garbage and
letting their little changing their
little boys to girls because they don't
like men it's just oh it's just awful
oh my gosh I was at my tournament well
my friends were playing in a volleyball
tournament this weekend and I go there
and there's all these dudes playing and
so I start you know I'm a YouTuber I
gotta get out my mic so I started
interviewing the people they're asking
if they're okay with it half the women
are like yeah it's fine what do you mean
it's fine
they're in our locker rooms they don't
but this is the thing I'm like it's like
women we want this power and control but
look what happens when we get it
it feminism with all this transgender
stuff it's fighting the women in the
butt you know literally because
even though they want power and they
want to rule and control men are proving
that they can't the men come into the
best athletes female athletes in the
world and they and they're not even that
great compared to men and they dominate
the women
you know God just made them bigger
stronger faster children know that their
dads are an authority whether the women
the wives give it to the dads or not
they know just because they are bigger
and stronger faster they have lower
stronger voices God made them the ones
in Authority they made us to be the
nurturers and the ones at home
gentle and we just Rebel women just
rebel against that
so what what is the true definition of
submission like what what should a
submissive like marriage a marriage look
like where the woman submits to her
husband
the mission in the Greek I don't know
Greek but I've heard this from my
husband he said
to come under like in the military to
come under and to to submit to them to
willingly allow them to lead and to obey
them I know people hate that word but
two heads make a monster every
institution on this planet has a leader
you can't have two presidents you can't
you know every every institution every
every company has a boss
and the same the family is an
institution and God made the husband the
head of the household he leads the
household in the way that he wants
unless it's in sin like a woman just
asked me this morning my husband wants
me to take the birth control pill I said
well you don't have to do that because
it can cause abortions it has horrible
horrible side effects that can destroy
your health you don't have to do
anything that's harmful like that to
yourself or murder you know so right
um but that's it's just letting your
husband lead and
it's not really that difficult and
practice makes perfect and it's it's
funny because even if women are married
to disobedient husbands the solution
that God gives them to win their
husbands is to be submissive to them
with you know show them Jesus Through
the way they live love them poor love I
know a woman who's married to a
difficult man
she is winning him because she's
constantly she's an example to me
because my husband's not difficult to
live with he's a great guy you know
loves the Lord's a great leader my kids
adore him but she just pours love and
grace upon him all the time and he is
just growing up into this amazing man
because the way she just lets him lead
doesn't nag isn't contentious with them
it's just kind
um God's ways are just so good they're
so they're so different than our natural
nature we think that we need to control
and manipulate and I was so good at that
about my husband and it just made our
marriage terrible
how did you how did you do it or what
are like the common things that women do
what before they're submissive
yeah like because I think a lot of times
I'll see people talk about how they're
submissive but and I don't know how I
can't tell I I don't I can't really
explain why but I see the way they
interact with each other and it doesn't
seem like she is
um but it's like it's subtle I don't
know how to describe it though well it
it um that couple I was just telling you
about before we went on that she's
marrying this man who has five children
who his wife died
he went to meet her parents just soon
after they met just like six weeks ago
they they started dating seven weeks ago
he went and saw her parents a week later
but they're like 31 34. they're they
weren't gonna fool around they're not
like probably when you meet a guy you're
not gonna just fool around you just you
want to know is this leading to marriage
or not you know and so he went and met
his parents and after he spent the a
couple a day with him he said I love the
way your mother is with your father she
just never interrupts him she doesn't
correct him she listens patiently and
looks at him when he's talking she is
affectionate with him
in every way she modeled that to her
children her daughters because one of
them is married to my son and so all
three of her daughters have had a really
easy time being submissive to their
husbands just kind and loving
um respectful the King James says
reverence and it's just such a beautiful
thing to see because I've seen couples I
saw couples like that when I was growing
up but I always in my mind was thinking
oh it's because he's just so perfect and
my husband is not you know
so but no she it and
she is doesn't have the strong
personality that I have she's more of a
pleaser so it comes natural to that type
of personality but even one of the
daughters like who my sons marry the
strong like me but because she was
modeled that she's very a very kind and
respectful wife to her husband so see
you'll know it when you see it you'll
know when a wife is letting her husband
leave by the way she just treats her
husband in public she would never say
anything negative about him she shows
her respect all the time in public
towards him and Tori children in the
home even the children can see that she
loves and respects her husband and that
he's the leader of the home whatever you
want honey you know
well yeah I had a recent red pill where
I realized I'm like most
women lead relationships I think in 2023
because
um I even I was thinking about how women
make 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions
and I'm like that means women are making
like whether it's a car a house like
they sell to the women meaning the women
are making all the decisions in the
household for the most part and I was
like
and so a lot of stuff like you think is
traditional actually isn't because the
man can't make a decision without the
woman arguing about it in a lot of
relationships I see
and you know they um said that before
women's right women couldn't have a
credit their own credit card and that
was really to protect the women because
when women didn't even want that because
men took their credit when if they got
into debt it was a man who had to go to
debtors prison you know it wasn't the
women who got so now since women have
their credit they own two-thirds of the
1.7 trillion dollar student loan debt
you know just yeah so
well I remember I remember being 18 and
like picking a college which I was gonna
I'm gonna talk to you about this too but
I remember thinking like my dad was like
do you want the more expensive one well
you'll have debt or the cheaper one
where you won't I picked the more
expensive why would I pick that like and
luckily like I um my dad this business
kind of took off so I didn't end up
having any but that was just because you
know I was lucky but and I was thinking
I'm like even me who you know people
would say is more logical I'm still a
woman you know I'm still gonna and so
you probably thought it was a better
College because it costs more me I don't
know well no I think I just wanted to go
there like I didn't have a good one okay
I didn't have a good reason I was like
oh everyone has debt I'll just pay it
off later
um American
what it's the American way to have debt
now
a massive amounts of debt now all these
young women I know who have babies have
to continue working because of their
debt it's like this is just so upside
down see when I went to college I went
to a private Christian College I didn't
want to I would have loved getting
married right out of high school
um and just starting having babies and
staying home with them that was always
just what I wanted to do but my dad
insisted I go to college even though he
didn't want my mom ever to work he
wanted her back in those days he wanted
them their wives to be home full-time he
wanted his wife to raise his children so
she never worked she was always home
full-time with us and I called him for
Dad's day yesterday and thanked him
again for that but um
um so anyway I went to a Christian
College small Christian College in Santa
Barbara Montecito which is beautiful
Oprah Winfrey has a big estate right
near there it's gorgeous
3 600 a year for everything and so my
roommate
that and that wasn't even that much
money even for if you consider back then
my roommate worked in the Summers to her
waitressing to pay for that you know
people weren't graduating with mass
amounts of debt back when I went in
college it was just something to do and
it wasn't that expensive it was I just
went to someone to find a husband you
know and find good friends so but now
now that it's tens of thousands of
dollars and they end up in hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt which keeps
them in bondage for many many years or
it puts that that burden on their
husband the Bible says that debt is
bondage you're you know bondage to the
debt and Who Wants To Be A Slave you
know so
what do you think about women going to
college do you think we should
no because right now they're all
indoctrination centers that's all they
are
um even the Christian ones are are
they're just they're just indoctrinating
women to become feminist with leftist
ideals they've contributed so much to
the destruction of our culture they I
think the only ones who should go to dog
um
colleges are men because women are
taking over the medical field and the
dental field which are taking jobs away
from men and they're hurting those
fields because they're not nearly as
reliable in those fields because they
have more health issues they have women
in the workforce suffer twice the amount
of stress related
illnesses diseases than men they weren't
we weren't created for the stress of the
workforce so they're taking away all
these jobs from the men and so they only
met people I think that who should go to
college are the ones who want to be
doctors and lawyers who need a college
education because most most jobs you
don't need a college education have you
know the men's could be plumbers
electricians and everything and
women who you know it's hard for me to
say about women who
you know when if like my friend who is
here that lived with us for a year she's
an OB nurse and I loved her and she
loved being a nurse but her hours were
terrible they're inhumane she'd get up
at six in the morning and wouldn't get
home until 8 PM she's 12 hour shifts 12
hour shifts and then they want to force
that shot on her and they had to wear a
mask all day you know teaching which
they also say is an ideal job for women
which I did is absolutely exhausting try
to keep being keep 30 children in order
it was I I was so exhausted when I came
home I just saw this thing about how
women Workforce deprive their husbands
sexually duh you're so exhausted after
being at work all day then you have to
take care of the kids in the house we
weren't created to do that all and the
only purpose for college it's not to
make you wiser or a better wife or
mother or homemade it's to um make
prepare women for the workforce that's
all it's only a purpose and now to
indoctrinate them into the leftist
agenda which a world is being destroyed
and we have to live with nothing and eat
nothing you know and die so the world
can be to have it
have nothing on it that seems like
that's their agenda you know well yeah
and my school was one of the first to
allow trans people in the dorms
and so down the hall from me like I I
would just was I was so into volleyball
when I was younger I just didn't care
about anything else I was just a
volleyball player so I didn't really
care at the time but I was looking at it
I'm thinking they were trying to
normalize that stuff and they did
because I would see these trans people
just walking around campus all the time
they had their own little thing and it's
like this was a Christian School
I mean I don't think they was like known
for being Christian clearly but yeah
most are just Christian name only
they're not Christian at all anymore
they don't like they don't want to stand
against culture and make stands against
all this stuff yeah and that I remember
talking with some of my cousins
um about the same sex when because
California when we voted on it I don't
know not even that long ago we voted
overwhelmingly not to allow same-sex
marriage but then a judge overruled it
and they were saying that oh that's okay
I said no it's such a slippery slope
it's not okay you know no God doesn't
want he want he designed this male and
female for each other you know one man
one woman and he's the one who created
marriage he's the one who defines it
it's only the only safe place for
marriage and sex to happen and so see
look where it sent us and people used to
be okay with pride month at St Mike but
now with what the transgender movement's
doing to the kids seems like people are
finally taking a stand against it but
I think God's judgment on our nation
it's too late we're just so
Wicked I'm so it's just so wicked you
think of his judgment on our nation's
too late
I think reversing it is too late I think
we are being judged with Wicked rulers
you know and and what's going on in our
culture and our leaders are trying to
destroy America and we deserve his
judgment actually
you know it's just so wicked what we're
doing to Children we've aborted I I was
talking with a black man at our church
yesterday and I was telling him his
wife's pregnant with her third I said is
this going to be your last babysit
probably you know I said
um you know this the roots of birth
control don't you Margaret's saying or
Planned Parenthood and he started
nodding his head and I go you know
Margaret sanger's goal was to get rid of
black people and 50 of babies being
aborted are black and he said oh it was
totally racism and so I I said I think
the whole birth control mentality that's
infected this land is just resulted in
we've killed more people in America than
any other nation in the history of the
world by far when you consider the peel
even aborts babies and the teleports
babies yes it does no way yeah
embryo one plant in the womb and the
pill will come in and shed that so once
it becomes an embryo it's a baby it's a
human being you know and it sheds that
so in fact my friend I was telling you
that live with us went through Midwifery
school is that you say it but what the
professor who's a leftist everything
said that you must be tell your patients
when you prescribe them the pill that it
can cause abortions they
they have a right to know
and so she said oh I will never
prescribe the birth control appeal ever
in fact she was working at UCSD which
had
abortions in that hospital and she
finally offered Scripps is a huge
hospital around here we have it's well
known around in San Diego
and it's Catholic and she found out that
they don't allow abortions they don't
even do vasectomies
and so she went there she used to work
at a big hospital in Houston but now she
after then she went to UCSD and now
she's at Scripps she's it's by far the
best hospital just the whole atmosphere
is so it's life it's pro-life and it's
just so that's where she wants to have
her babies that the lord they're already
having five babies that she's adopting
but if she if the Lord blesses her
they're gonna have more and that's where
she wants to go and she loves working
there just because of that mentality the
mentality of Life wow that's so crazy
the birth control stuff is it all of
them like everyone
all the birth control pills can cause
abortions yeah wow plus they mess up
your health yeah really horribly
horribly they can make you infertile
they're in the water system and I'm
taking down men's testosterone they're
just wrecking wreaking havoc on the
health of people yeah well
and that's what I remember I had this
thought when I was younger I was like
because I remember all my friends where
I was like 16 and all my friends were on
birth control and I wouldn't go on it
and they were all saying like oh we
should like you should it helps with
this this and this and I don't look at
him not a science you know I'm not a
die-hard I don't know the science behind
it but I was just like it cannot be good
to turn off your reproductive like
that's what I said
healthy to stop something natural
you know this but my mom my grandma was
raised in a church that taught that
drugs doctors and demons were synonymous
yeah so she never took her kids to the
doctor never gave him the shots so we
didn't give our kids shots and I never
get took them to well care anything but
I'm thankful for my mom raising us to
fear drugs so none of it we rarely ever
took drugs only in emergency situations
so the three of us never were interested
in any type of you know the drugs going
around the kid with the kids that were
taking and um I raised my kids that way
too that drugs are only for emergency
purposes that's it but they don't heal
they don't heal anything they cover
symptoms the only drugs that really heal
are antibiotics but other than that they
just
you know they don't heal a lot of times
and they have come with a ton of side
effects
so like one woman was sharing that she
had horrible acne when she had
had was on the birth control pill I was
just listening to this woman who
transitioned and she was on testosterone
and now she's talking out against it and
how the testosterone her voice will
never be the same
her breasts are gone of course she's got
receding hairline that will never grow
back
and it's just so
so because we were not created to have
high doses of testosterone in our bodies
the female body was not created for that
well and what I realized is all these
policies they're trying to play God
oh yeah yeah and so and I realized even
with the women voting because everyone
thinks I'm so nuts for this opinion
because I I didn't always think this
okay because I kind of just thought
everyone voted until I realized like
when you have two votes in a household
like it takes away from marriage because
you're supposed to submit to your
husband's Authority and he's supposed to
have like the final say and so now you
have two parties like voting for
different people and I lived with a
Christian couple like that where like
one voted Democrat one voted Republican
and I was like
I just don't think that's like good for
a family to be arguing over politics in
in house and she's negating his vote
she's stealing his vote Yeah by voting
opposite of what he does
I don't know how Christian can vote
Democrat anyway that's just
well and she um they were actually like
the nicest couple they let me like stay
with them for like they were actually so
nice but it wasn't like
like when I was in this this church I
just couldn't like something was just
off and I couldn't figure out what like
she was on birth control she didn't want
kids like you know they both voted
differently and like it was just
something about it I was like this isn't
what God wanted marriage to look like
like I don't know it was just like my
gut at the time and I didn't understand
it because I don't know I think I was
like 21 22. I I didn't really get it but
I was like something's just like off
here so what what are like issues that
you see with modern day churches
um women
um
we've been trying to take control over
the churches there there's this huge
thing going on I'm sure you've seen it
where women 1B pastors and most churches
have women pastors and
and women in leadership and that is the
beginning of the destruction of a church
as women in leadership it's our church
is all men and I the first biblically
solid Church we've ever gone to all men
Elders 12 men Elders Godly men
know God's word in fact we had one of
the one of the pastors teach our Sunny
school last week on Ephesians 5 20
23 through 25
22-24 about wives submitting to your
husbands as the husband is the head of
the wife the wife submit to the husbands
in everything the wisely yeah and so
usually pastors whenever they teach on
submission they'll say that um they'll
teach everything that submission is and
it's not abuse blah blah blah and they
won't ever teach what submission is like
you didn't even really know what it is
because pastors don't but this pastor
totally taught it I just praised him and
praised him and praised him after that
class I said thank you for T he said and
it goes all the way back to Creation a
lot of people say it just happened after
the fall but Jesus erased that curse you
know no it's for Authority but um yeah
women trying to take over and
these men
like our last church was completely
going woke instead of the day after Roe
v Wade was overturned a year ago he
praised Juneteenth he didn't say one
thing that was two a couple years ago
because our pastor we were actually we
were at our our good church and he we
talked ton about the pastors talked on
about Roe v Wade being overturned but um
he talked to and his one of their
children supported BLM and
she signs her names with pronouns now
so it's just a slippery slope you start
disobeying God in one area and that's a
huge area
then that's taking taking away the
authority the biblical Authority
structure out of the church then the
church is downhill so I believe that
most churches are incredibly lukewarm
and Revelation says that God's going to
spit those lukewarm churches out of his
mouth and he talks about Jezebel you
allow that women Jezebel to teach you
know and he so
that's the main problem of the churches
and people don't know scripture there's
all these false teachers out there but
they don't know scripture enough to
under see a false teacher or false talk
Doctrine when they hear it so are you a
Christian
I'm Catholic I did I was in a Christian
church for a couple years
um but I I also think like the Catholic
church is kind of starting to lose its
marbles a bit with the the new pope and
stuff like I think um it's unfortunate
because I I think there's a lot of
people that take a lot of pride in being
Catholic but I think there's like woke
people that have kind of infiltrated it
too in everything they're infiltrating
everything yeah it's and it's really
unfortunate because well thankfully
you're thankfully your mind has not if
you read Romans 1 go home and read
Romans then when tonight
but it helps you to understand what's
going on in our culture and you have not
been another guy Andrew John wait
Anthony Johnson he interviewed me he's
not a Christian he's an outright atheist
but he can see
what's going on he can see the
wickedness taking over in our culture
and I told him you have not God has not
turned you over to a reprobate mind you
still have a soft heart and I told him
you do believe in God because all
creation shouts that there's a God you
know there are no atheists really even
clearly
strange that that you is not even maybe
not a born-again Christian can clearly
see the harm that feminism is doing yet
so many women who claim to be Christians
cannot well and you know what that was
the biggest red pill moment for me was
when I realized like college is feminism
because those are women's most fertile
and that's what I realized I was like
chasing a volleyball like instead of
carrying having babies
correct yeah and I and it was like I
just couldn't even believe it I was like
that was just what I thought we were
supposed to do you know we got her and
no I meant like I'm going to college and
like I didn't I know but that's what
we're supposed to do in our culture from
the time you're little people ask what
you want to be when you grow up and all
I want to be as a wife and mother but I
couldn't say that yeah you know you
can't say that
yeah and that's what that I realized I
was like oh my gosh this is this is
crazy because
um
I just never like would have thought
that college is feminism and then when I
found out that the birth rate and the
win rate of women going to college it's
like opposite I was like
and of course I found out that feminism
started way before the vote because
birth rates have been dropping since the
1800s I guess I thought it was the 1900s
but I I looked it up recently and I
guess like the the before the
suffragettes there was like a whole
nother it was the Enlightenment I don't
I don't know the ins and outs you know
but
yeah do you know when it started what
with Eve
in the garden
that's when it started
it did she rebelled against Authority
she was she rebelled against God
Almighty yeah you know and the husband's
Authority and so it started there we can
thank our mother Eve
we're so critical as women like what are
tips that we can use in relationships in
order to interact that's so funny
because
in the churches
the ones who are the so critical about
anything going on the music that it's
always women
um
you're my favorite person on the
internet right it's just really sad
well that's why we're quarreling in
contentious with our husbands because
we're discontent and were We complain we
like to complain we like to be
nitpickers and so how do we not complain
um I was very sick for 30 years raising
my children the whole entire time I was
raising my children I was very very ill
first with parasites Mass amounts of
parasites like chemotherapy drugs to get
off of them destroyed my gut then I had
a brain tumor brain surgery and then I
had my neck fusion because I had so much
pain in my neck from a lot of car
accidents and running running into a
play glass window when I was young and
then it grew back so I'd have another
brain surgery and so I was so sick
during my children's childhood but I I
knew and I so I missed out on all so
many Christmases Easter's thanksgivings
birthdays vacations because I was
homesick in pain and I was thinking just
my walk yesterday how much God used that
time to refine me and I was trying to
put into words what how he refined me
and one of them was remind me that
self-pity is satanic because when you're
just sitting around feeling sorry for
yourself you're
the setting that God isn't Sovereign
you're not trusting the Lord and what
he's doing in your life and godliness
with contentment is great gain learning
to just be content and I decided early
on when my kids were young when I was so
sick that just because I was miserable I
was not going to make my life my
children's lives miserable in fact my
oldest daughter just told me multiple
times recently I don't even remember you
being so sick mom because you never
complained you always were joyful
and then it's like I know my personality
for the last five years I felt finally a
lot better so my personality has come
out more because when you're so sick and
you lose your personality but I didn't
complain I smiled at them a lot and I
was kind
um so just godliness with contentment is
great gain and when I start feeling
myself going into a pit of depression
and wanting to Gumble at grumbling and
playing and really feeling like I was
gonna lose it emotionally
I would just remind myself that the joy
of the Lord is my strength and I can do
all things through Christ who
strengthens me and because the battle's
in the mind it's you know so I've
decided I'm gonna love my husband the
way he is I'm not going to let that
bother me anymore I'm not because I used
to hate the way I was a healthy food nut
no drugs you know I was raised by
organic health food that when it wasn't
even in so I and he was right he was
raised on pizza and donuts you know so
that was what we thought about all the
time you know and if I even I heard him
a mentor he mentors couples all the time
I heard of upstairs going
if she even said the word salad to me I
would get angry you know because after I
just I went I ran up to him after I read
this book and said I'm so sorry I Repent
I
I'm a terrible wife I don't want to do
that anymore hold me accountable so I
couldn't men say anything about the way
he ate for a long time I just now I can
say some things in a kind way and he'll
either do it or not and I just get I
don't doesn't bother me you know I don't
I don't ever get angry with him anymore
I don't ever quarrel with him I can't
remember the last time we had an
argument
there's peace in our home I remember us
mentoring this one couple they were on
the verge of divorce
big this big guy just
just built you know and she would just
lose it just have temper tantrums and
Ken goes how about
whenever you do that your husband just
gives you a big bear hug and holds you
and she goes that sounds really good and
that was like 12 years ago we met
through it and they're so happily
married now sometimes it just needs you
know women just need to hear that you
don't have to argue with your husband
it's not your job to control and change
them you don't have to always be
critical of them because that makes you
ugly in his eyes start smiling at him
instead be kind to him treat him the way
you want him to treat you like women
will tell me how horrible I'd go Mentor
women in for the first hour they tell me
how horrible their husbands were then
I'd say okay you tell me how what kind
of a wife you are to them that's when we
get down to the nuts and bolts you know
because most of them don't know how to
be a wife they don't know how to be a
loving and kind gentle wife to their
husbands well that's what I realized I
was like we have a whole generation of
people that just don't know how to like
do anything and so I was even thinking
of myself like every day I'd go
um out of school I'd go to volleyball
practice and then I'd do basketball I
did two sports and I was really good at
it
um but I was training for five hours a
day
what no no wonder I didn't learn to cook
till I was you know 20 I don't know two
years I'm 26 so two two three years ago
and I'm a lot better than I was but I'm
like I'm starting so late in life
um but I realized that most women don't
know these days yeah I'm I'm improving I
mean I am improving but it's not that
hard yeah yeah well and that's what I
realized I was like so because in a way
it's like it almost turned us into men
because Sports is something that men do
and what I realized too was that playing
sports raises women's testosterone
levels
so we're more competitive it's like a
lot of us have a little bit lower of
voice it's a lot of girl I noticed like
female athletes a lot of us are Daddy's
Girls so it's kind of like we are we
wanted to like we're like who's your dad
yeah yeah it's like we're the we're the
um
the sun there that they kind of raised
us like a sun you know but the whole
group is a feminism was to make women
into men but when I was in the hospital
dying 20 years ago from my brain tumor
and they did every single blood test on
me possible trying to figure out what
was wrong with me before they got the
results of the MRI and saw what was
wrong
um I saw the hormone the testosterone
levels and
the women's testosterone levels are like
25 to 75 men's are 250 to 850. wow no
wonder we're so different you know 10
times the testosterone at least as women
you know so even your even though your
testosterone might be raised it just his
oh the maximum it can goes to 85 you
know over near men's you know that's um
I spoke to a hormone doctor and he told
me that that's a lot of times why people
think they're the opposite genders their
hormones are off
well I think it would I think it's
easier for men's hormones to be
um because the estrogen and the water
from the pills and all the Plastics and
the chemicals they're exposed to that is
getting rid of their testosterone and
the sperm counts really half of what my
dad's was you know when he was 60 the
young mans are and so I think I think I
think it's harder for a women's
testosterone to go up but we could be
Heavy too heavy in estrogen it's not
good for women either but it's really
damaging men and I think the whole
purpose of feminism and the leftists and
satanic agenda is to destroy men you
destroy men you could easily take over a
nation when you have strong good men
you're not gonna be able to do that and
that's what our nation was founded upon
with strong good men who wrote the an
incredible Constitution and designed our
nation so we live in a fairy tale of of
how the world has always been America
has been the greatest country that's
ever existed and but the message but
then you know Saints agenda was to
feminism destroy the family and the way
you destroy the families to destroy the
men
so and you destroy the men by getting
the women out of the home where she has
no time for her husband you know so they
go off to porn or whatever
so it's just yeah it's working our
culture has definitely just because
women can't be men no matter how much we
try to be men
no matter how good a swim or a woman is
or how fast a runner is a mediocre man
who's a swimmer a mediocre man is going
to beat those women and look at the cops
the women cops and the military they're
destroying the military
and the firemen who wants you know if
you're being raped you don't want to see
a woman running to the rescue you
you know the same thing I have said I I
just did this I did a talk TV which is
like a British TV station here that's
what I said I said ban women from the
police get him out of there the military
get him out of there too we don't and
the fire department God created man to
be the Protectors of society he had men
20 and older going off to war he in all
throughout scripture men that were
protecting the women and the children I
don't understand women's mentality to
even want to go in those preventions
because you see these films of of
um man bad men and cops coming and it's
the men the male cops who get on the
ground fighting him and the women are
jumping around you know you know the
women cops they can't do anything you
know they're worthless
they don't have the strength and you
know what I realized because we have so
many girls on the show that say they
want a guy that out earns them right and
what I realized is like women under like
35 we I think we out earn men in a lot
of major cities but it's because we can
monetize Beauty like you know Kylie
Kylie Jenner and Kim Kardashian might be
billionaires but they don't contribute
as much to society as say Elon Musk or a
similar billionaire
that's a guy and so it's like you have
all these girls that think they're
better than men when because they make
more but a lot of times it's like you
know I got paid more at my sales job
because I was I was a girl like it
wasn't because wow your sales person
right you know because the leftist
agenda they and
making everything equal but they're not
really making equal they're punishing
men but I would rather have babies and
grandchildren than
a career that makes a lot of money yeah
what
um what do you think about women working
what are your opinions on women well
like I said earlier um women have twice
the stress related diseases heart
disease cancer and diabetes there's been
in the workforce we weren't created for
the stress of the workforce and um they
miscarry they're more infertile they
their their marriages are the divorce
rate is higher so you know even single
women it's hard I
for them to be in the workforce just we
were created for the homes because
biblically we're supposed to be under
our dad's Authority until marriage and
then under our husband's Authority God
wants men good men protecting and
providing for the women and even in
first Timothy 5 we're given instruction
for widows the older women are supposed
to be taken care of by their families
and Paul never says go out and find a
job the older the the families are First
supposed to provide for them if they
don't have family then relatives and no
relatives in the churches or to provide
for the and the younger women he says
Get Married get married have children
guide the home he doesn't say go out and
get a job and support yourself and never
in scripture does it is is there a
command for women to go out and provide
that's the man's job and it's but now
with women having the earning power that
they have and it's only because of men
and what they've built for us and
daycare the birth control pill Public
Schools women could not have the careers
that they have and do what they do
without what men have invented and built
and sustained so it's all a kind of a
fantasy actually because I watch this
reality show years ago I wish I I wrote
a post about it but this couple of
modern day couple she's very leftist
they're very leftist an old couple more
traditional went back to living like the
1800s for a month
and I'll never forget a scene she's in
the kitchen
and the guys are doing a plow out in the
field with a horse and she goes I'm
stuck in the kitchen because I can't do
most of that stuff I all I have to do is
in the kitchen you know and and taking
care of the home it's like yeah that's
how it was before man invented all these
things that allowed women to act like
they're men and leave their homes and go
into the workforce and
I don't know you I drive by where
they're up on telephone poles electric
things and it's always men and doing
construction and rebuilding roads and
buildings it's always manned upon the
high tower it's there are women they're
the ones that are on the oil rigs and
doing the hard sustaining work of
culture not women I'm waiting for the
there's a building being built next door
I'm waiting for all the women the
feminists to line up and go build that
building it won't be equal and that's
that's what I realized I was like women
are fighting for equality but we can't
have it because we literally cannot do
the jobs that make Society run so why
are we being paid more now under 30 in
major cities
think if all of a sudden men just
disappeared all men just were taken away
how long do you think women would
survive
not long like all of a sudden
electricity is out how do we fix that
you know who knows how to go to the
major electrical things whatever or
whatever or Plumbing or the sewer system
or whatever so let's say all the women
are taken out how long would the men
survive until they died off
what is your advice for picking a
husband
my advice to women is that they be Godly
because when they're Godly they're good
when they definitely love the Lord in
his ways kind all I know are good men in
my life
um my husband my dad my sons they're
just my son lost they're just good men
they wouldn't think of actually harming
a woman they protect provide they work
hard and then I'm working hard they you
must marry man who works hard you want a
man who provides for you and you must
find one who wants you doesn't expect
you to work and provide and doing that
but wants you to be able to be home have
children take care of the children
that's that's always what I those are
the two if you can find a Godly Man a
true godly man and a man who works hard
that's why I told my daughters look for
that no no six foot six figures nothing
no no no no
my husband was gonna be a missionary my
dad warned me about marrying him because
I was always going to be poor and I said
dad I you know
he works hard he's incredibly
intelligent he didn't turn out to be a
missionary he went a different route but
um
so
and we had zero many I didn't marry for
that at all and I did want tall because
I'm I'm old I was five eight I'm five
seven now but I I wanted to tell a guy
at least taller than me
um he's six one but and and you know I
think you have to be attracted to them
somewhat I feel bad when women are in
their 30s though and they met a man
who's really good Godly Man works really
hard and she they meet all these
qualifications but they say I'm not
attracted to him it's like well you can
become attraction because attraction
comes and goes I mean you don't have
attraction I've been married almost 43
years you don't have constant attraction
for your husband when you're mad and
angry with him or whatever you know or
sick and suffering so
um the good Godly and working hard are
far more than attraction but if you've
really prayed about the spouse you like
my husband and I we just connected when
we met this is the first man that we
just connected we just had a really good
time we had the same goals and that's
another thing is having the same goals
in life wanting the same things and we I
just wanted babies I'd be home and he
wanted that too so
I'm shocked no six-figure athlete
Entertainer no no
you know what I don't know if you want
that kind of guy they're
um this is a Tim Tebow godly man but
most of them it
slept with a ton of women and I don't
know I I think you just wanted a good
man you don't want a man who's used
women
you want man whose Treasures it will
treasure his wife will treasure you you
might not be able to find a virgin you
know
um but God redeems and restores that and
even women who are not aren't virgins
have can be great God's transforming
power can be great wives and mothers you
know anything we've done in our past God
can none of us are perfect we're all we
all have baggage somewhere we've all
done things we regret
but in you'll still never find a perfect
man
be just fine when that
um you connect with you have the same
visions and goals
a good man you want a good man make sure
your dad and I know you love your dad
you told me that make sure your dad
he cannot your dad can ask him any
questions he wants
and that your dad loves him and approves
of him because you love your dad so much
you definitely absolutely want his
approval for the man that you marry
that's really important
what about for a wife
uh has been looking for a wife yeah
um
have her read my stuff and and if she
doesn't like it don't marry
I tell him
man books and if or just one of my books
and if she is repulsed by it don't marry
her you know what you do not want to
marry a feminist and then that's so hard
for men to find even in the Christian
Schools my one of my nephews just said
they're all feminists well they're in
college to be career women you know
yeah no in the other thing that's tough
is like women have so much more power
and like from a young age when it comes
to like sexual options so I almost feel
like sometimes young men in the church
get taken advantage of by predatory
women because they don't know any better
because you know she's been sleeping
around since she was like 15 because she
can but the average 15 year old is just
not the same you know and then you know
10 years later or whatever it is he
comes in and like they kind of do the
whole
not that how do I put it not that I'm
against like Redemption but I think
sometimes like the church kind of tells
guys to be naive like they don't warn
them about predatory women as much as I
think they should
I warned my sons my sons had eyes wide
openness
to Warren I did the whole Purity culture
thing and had him read books and went to
a purity camp and and talked you know
and I just said you don't date a woman
until you're ready to marry her unless
you want to marry her they're not you're
not to fool around with them
um you know and I if they so we were
real we weren't like they had to
we didn't we're
they didn't have to have a chaperone or
anything you know but which I don't
think those are bad I don't think like
what the how the Duggars raise their
children were bad because they all have
great marriages they did they kissed the
first time on their wedding date and
they were they were very serious about
purity and sexual Purity and I think
that's an admirable and um but I just
taught my kids they knew
that beauty of sex in marriage and the
destruction of sex outside of marriage
how what how much it could cause so they
were all well that's what men they need
teacher boys from the time they were
little from the time you know they were
little and so they knew and they were
thankful they're you know none of them
say we're we were considered the strict
parents but none of them say we were too
strict they were there they thank us for
the boundaries we that we set around
them and even in high school my boys had
to be home I think at 10 you know that
was because I I just wanted I just knew
nothing like one of my cousins as a copy
says nothing happens good after midnight
never but so special times I'd let him
stay out later but we just we protect we
did everything we could protect our kids
as long as they lived under our roof
what do you think is the difference
between parents where like the kids grow
up to resent them for the strictness and
the like the ones that grow to
appreciate it because I've seen both
like you know the stereotypical pastor's
daughter or like that sort of thing like
what do you think is the difference
I don't know both Ken and I were were
very eye to eye on the way we trained
and disciplined our kids and we were
very strict but they knew they were very
loved very loved and we were very strict
with you know disciplining them spanking
them before the age of five so they
don't even remember us disciplining them
you know but they just always we time to
obey from a very young age so they
obeyed us and we didn't have terrible
twos we didn't have rebellious teenagers
we did they just always we taught them
to respect us from a really young age so
they always respected us and listened to
our opinions and um because we taught
that to them and we were Joyful We let
them know like a lot of kids raised in
quote Christian homes walk away from the
faith and from what from what I've
observed it's my the friends I know who
are critical
complaining negative
whose children walked away from the Lord
my grand you know I shouldn't say
nothing that's so true but then I my my
kids saw that and my mom loved Jesus and
was joyful so all three of us love Jesus
and you know and so we raised our kids
um
strict boundaries but they knew we
always gave them reasons why we gave
them we didn't just say because it's I
because I said so we'd always try to
back it up with scripture and they saw
the love of Jesus and it's that living
for Jesus is a wonderful thing it's not
a it's not an awful thing it's not
negative and quoralism and joyless you
know so
yeah
wow that's so because all of our are
they all walk in truth they're all great
kids they all they're all our oldest
just turned 40 and they're all in their
30s they all have families of their own
and they're all doing great and we're
just so blessed we just are so thankful
because I know some families who did
everything right you know and they've
had one prodigal when they all go astray
you kind of wonder about the parenting
but they have one prodigal like one
woman said that she sent her daughter
off to College University and she's
totally left us now see we wouldn't do
that we didn't we hope we homeschooled
him when we saw that oh I didn't want to
send my kids my boys to Junior High I I
felt like I was spinning them off to a
cliff because I knew it was great so I
started homeschooling them then we were
gonna maybe send one of them to the
local high school because he's a really
good athlete he'd have been the point
guard there in the picture
but then a good friend of mine called up
and told me what was going on how the
girls were chasing the boys and what
they were doing to them ran upstairs I
don't want that so we sent them to a
pride little private Christian High
School that was incredible so we just
did whatever we could throughout the
years
each one we did a little bit differently
what we felt what they needed and
that's what we how we raised our
children
you mentioned 40. so you said women you
have a video talking about how women
lose their minds after 4 40. they start
they start because of living in
Rebellion to their husbands
so for so many years being contentious
that they go mad and I've seen it with
women they can no longer really think
straight and you can't bitterness
there's a verse in the Bible that says
that bitterness defiles many and when
you're always angry you're bitter and
bitterness you gotta pull that thing out
from the root you cannot have bitterness
in your life my parents were were not
bitter even though they fought
constantly with each other they never
were bitter towards other people or held
grudges even with each other they could
still you know do okay but so my husband
was raised in a home like that too and
so my husband I never had bitterness or
or held anything against anybody so my
children are raised that way so none of
them are either I have that problem so
that's one thing you have to really nip
the bud in with your children if you see
any type of bitterness or unforgiveness
or holding things against people we just
have to forgive and pour Grace upon
people yeah what do you what do you mean
by bitterness like could I have an
example
um
when I'm so sick
one of my sisters
well both my sisters they didn't there
was something that they were holding
against me and they didn't come and see
me through for many years
and I could have easily easily been
bitter and angry towards them and
I would allow myself to and I just
decided that I was just gonna love them
and be kind to them and not be angry and
bitter towards them
and I now we have a close relationship
and and one of them's apologized and we
love each other deeply you know there's
just some
bad thinking going on on their part
bitterness always stems from Bad
thinking I think not really
understanding things
but um so just being angry being angry
at someone and not forgiving them and
holding on to that
and not letting it go and just always
keeping it against them a lot of eyes do
that with our husbands they're bitter
towards our husband and that I was that
way with my husband because he wouldn't
eat the way I wanted to eat how do you
how do you balance
um
because I would say I don't really hold
grudges but sometimes like at the same
time like people will say oh you're
letting people walk all over you
or you have no backbone like that sort
of thing
you know people say to me because I
watch my grandkids so much that I get
exhausted and well I hope they're not
taking advantage of you people will say
to me your kids are not take it's like
my goal in life is to serve other people
you know and I I just don't even think
about that of being a door matter like
women say oh you're a doormat if you
submit to your husband no you're not
you're obeying God Jesus said the
greatest of all is the servant of all so
I'll know exactly the situation here but
at my kids if I'm too tired I'll let him
know you know okay I I'm hitting the
wall here you have to take over you know
and they're fine yeah well that's what I
realized on the show when girls would
say like I did so much for him because
it's like so common they'll say I'll
like you give and you give and you give
and what I realized is like red pill
moment I'm like it actually says more
about her because she's keeping score
and you're not supposed to keep score
right you're very wise for a woman who
doesn't know her Bible very well we're
not supposed to keep score we're
supposed to outdo each other it's not a
50 50 thing it's a hundred a hundred you
know you yeah you just I I used to be
that way you know we we'd argue about
who does more and it's like what a
stupid thing to argue about well that's
so stupid what I realized too because
I've definitely done that before and
like I even think of a time in high
school I did that to my dad where I was
like because my dad's just not the most
um
like can I put it like he just shows
that he loved like just like men like
they'll show you they love you more than
tell you right like they're just more
like they're gonna show you and I
remember one day I was like kind of
complaining about my dad and my mom just
looked at me and she was just like he
does this for you he does this for you
he does this like she just listed all of
the things that he does for me every
single day and that I was just being a
brat about and it really humbled me and
I realized like a lot of times we're
focused like on what they don't do for
us but like you don't notice all the
stuff they like usually when you're mad
like there's more that they're doing
than you realize
I know that's totally just a
self-centered self-pity selfish attitude
It's All About Us instead of just
forgetting ourselves
and living for other people you know and
that's you because I used to be so
selfish I wanted my husband to serve me
even when I was with my mom on vacations
I want to do everything and now I love
serving people I I and I'm so much more
fulfilled and happy and joyful actually
not keeping score but just serving
people and loving people because that's
what we're that's where we find the
greatest fulfillment not all that other
garbage how did you train yourself to do
that
in the mine
like like you do you see things and go
oh that just doesn't seem right you know
and just you know reading my Bible every
day and um knowing truth and taking
every thought captive to The Obedience
of Christ it's sale in
I read in one of my devotionals that
self-pity is satanic and that was
life-changing because that whole
thinking that you were saying is just
self-pity it's satanic and instead
taking eye our eyes off of ourself and
putting them on to others and wanting
what's best for them and serving and
loving them and as a mother and a wife
you must have that attitude if you're
going to be a good wife and mother you
cannot go into marriage thinking what's
he gonna do for me happy wife happy life
garbage you have to go into into
marriage thinking what kind of wife am I
going to be to him how am I going to
make his life better how am I going to
be that help me that God calls me to be
that's how you're going to marriage so
you also had a very controversial um
quote where you said men
want debt free
virgins without tattoos
yes that was a Blog that was a blog post
that went viral about it was in 17 2017
or 18 I remember of it the minute I
published that thing
it went
wild wild
I went up stairs and told Ken what I'd
done he goes Lori I'm told when my sons
he goes mom
but
um
it started a good conversation but what
was shocking was so many Christian women
coming out against me
like
um well what about women who aren't
virgins it's like
what about young women who are virgins
don't you want me warning them you know
and then I even really I didn't even
really and it was a woman who had been
writing me who suggested that title and
she didn't have the tattoos either the
tattoos but men that's what really most
men do want that who what man wanted a
woman who slept around a ton
who was covered with tattoos who has a
ton of debt to me that was just like
common sense but common senses flew out
the window but I got nailed from
everywhere except for a lot of big
magazines and Good married in America
they want to interview me and I didn't
want it because I knew they were just
gonna although I probably I could stand
on my own two feet I know against
anybody but um a woman from USA Today
contacted me and she said I agree with
you I'd love to interview I said okay so
we had a great interview it was a great
article that she wrote up on me great
she got fired shortly afterwards but but
anyway
um yeah so would you want to ask about
it
oh I wanted to know what prompted this
and well yeah because a woman was
writing me into it a woman was writing
me and asked she wrote me frequently and
was just talking about what college does
to women
you know so because College gets women
sexually active and it and it debt and
then the tattoos are exploding and they
just get so gray and ugly as you age so
ugly full of toxins are not healthy for
you
um
so I mean just you see these women with
them all over their bodies and
my sister had happened to us like no
ah I tried every time I go home I'm like
I will pay
I will pay you money to take these off I
will pay she's so stubborn she won't do
it yeah none of my children wanted to do
any of that they never I think they knew
what our answer would be they knew us
well enough my mom was so mad she was
like do not but
once you're an adult they go do what
they want but I know that women who have
slept around who had debt and who have
tattoos can have fabulous marriages when
they repent and their new creatures in
Christ and they become Godly submissive
wives I know they can have great
marriages that post was written to young
women
who have not gone that route because
there's a lot of scars going that route
and a lot of harm done to women and it's
if you want a good godly man it's a lot
easier to get a good lovely man if you
haven't slept around and have tattoos
and debt so but I you know I a lot of
things I write offend a lot of people
well yeah what's the alternative tell
them to sleep around get tattoos get a
ton of debt like
I know people will say this to me and
they'll be like you're not a virgin I'm
like I'm so I'm not but it's still a
better route like I'm not married like
it's a better route to go to go that way
you know and it's funny I had a cousin
who was homeschooled
um
and I thought they were so nuts her
parents I was like when I was a kid I
was like they're homeschooling them
they're like they're so sheltered all
this stuff you know she's married with
two kids right now so I'm like you know
honestly like the parents knew what they
were doing yep
she trained they trained them up in the
ways of the Lord the good ways God
created us
and his ways are best for us he created
us to be mothers look at our bodies
rest looms monthly periods eggs ovaries
fallopian tubes
hormones we were created to have
children and men were created to give
them to give what we need to have
children you know I mean it's just it's
so obvious to anyone who has eyes to see
but feminists tried to convince women
otherwise you know that that no we were
created for the workforce we weren't
created for marriage and having children
you know it's like
so I am going to give you a couple
phrases I have heard on my show we're
gonna close it off with this I'm gonna I
don't want to give your your it's gonna
be so funny your response all right okay
so women tell me I need a man who can
handle me
yikes she's not gonna be have a good
marriage no she needs a man who
she's gonna love and adore in reverence
and submit too that's how he that which
handled me oh good luck good luck
finding a man who wants to handle you I
mean it might look really cute at first
because she's cute and bubbly or
whatever but long term
that's a terrible terrible terrible term
so other women they'll say
who cares about body count men that care
about that are just insecure
no they're not insecure
they don't like thinking of a woman
being with a bunch of different men and
comparing and the things I've heard from
young women who had slept with what they
knew that I just had no I was originally
when I got married that I had no clue of
you know I was like oh garbage you know
it's experiment with each other learn
from each other
um they do care most men I don't know
about most men actually in these days
and age where everything is so corrupted
I would still say most men still want
women virgins or women who have not
slept around that much you know because
it the STDs the infertility risk factor
um abortions
women suffer so much more from for
fornication than men do because of the
way that we're built
and so and emotional the emotional
attachment the Heartbreak
uh it's like I said God Can Transform
anybody but
men are taking a lot bigger risk if they
marry a woman with a high body count of
have being able to have children and
and them being faithful to them because
if they've been promiscuous outside of
marriage seeing me I've only had sex
with one man for 43 years almost
the thought of having sex with anyone
else is
disgusting you know I just can't even
fathom because I I've only had it with
my name I remember on my honeymoon night
thinking man I'm glad I'm married to
this man God I would not want to just
this is not just something you just slip
into oops you know
I'm glad I'm married to this man and we
can learn this and learn this together
you know and and that's how it should be
on your honeymoon tonight you're both
awkward you know it's
but um yeah women who have slept around
a lot have a It prepares them for a
divorce because they'll fall into an
affair I've had men flirt with me and
kind of go after me since I've been
married but I had no desire
to wanna
have sex with them or have an affair
no desire so it's a it's a virginity
sexual Purity is a protection for
marriage
and I saved myself my mom told me one
thing she didn't teach us a lot about
purity or anything she was I would say
she was a Godly woman at all but she
said you want to be able to stand before
the man that you want to marry and say
she told me this when I was like 12 or
13.
I've saved myself for you I thought yeah
I do and so I did
that was all she had to say and that was
all I I shouldn't take me to Purity
camps and talk to them like but it was
well it was a sex fornication was
rampant when I was in high school too
because I was in high school in the 70s
after the 60s sexual Revolution so as
RAM and all my friends were sleeping
with their boyfriends but it just never
appealed to me it's like well why do I
want to do that you know
I just had an ick it was an X Factor to
me you know
until I said
so that's in fallacy no it the chances
of having a faithful wife with a woman
with a high body count is very slim I'm
sure there are statistics that prove
that
so um
another one you know another phrase is I
don't cook I don't clean
let me tell you how I got this ring and
then you know they list some sexual acts
is a popular song that the teenagers are
singing nowadays
that's so bad you happen to this how
he's out they're actually marrying these
women without who don't know how to cook
who don't know how to act just because
of what they do to them sexually
yeah
whoa I'll just remember we had one girl
who my younger son was dating one time
she came over and we're all eating
around the table and she goes I don't
even know how to cook I don't I don't
want to cook and right then there my son
just thought nope she's not for me no
you want a woman who could pick but um
that those marriages aren't laid on a
good foundation at all that's because
because you know what women are very
sexually available to men before
marriage it seems like to get the man
but from my husband mentoring men from
what I've seen they become not sexually
available after marriage they use it as
a manipulation tactic because they're
not good women they don't have integrity
or morals they're just going to get a
man because of how they give them sex
you know
um so they're going to use that they're
going to use that power against their
husbands once they get married well so
men don't like that well and that's what
irritated me about like I was even
tweeting like recently about cheating
and I was saying like you should work
through cheating if you can like I'm not
for it right but adultery in marriage
yeah yeah like um I was saying that that
should be the goal right that should the
goal should be to work through it
because I hear about the men whose wives
haven't slept with them in years
I know and so it's like a lot of times
they'll cheat but it's like well what
did you I mean I I don't want to sound
like I'm condoning it but what did you
expect like well that's why we're not
supposed to drive deprive each other in
the Bible because our lack of
self-control God warns men and women not
to deprive your spells your spouse
because a lack of self-control but I had
a woman she was my Bible study leader
and her husband had an affair and she
had three children and she had
determined she was going to win her
husband back so even she remembers one
time even helping wash his car and
waving goodbye as he went off to his
girlfriend but she fought she fought by
loving him praying Grace upon him she
won him back it took him a year after
they were together he finally apologized
I have other women I've mentored who won
their husbands back after adultery and
they went on to Mentor do premarital
counseling at our church for years and
had a great marriage until he died and
other other women who have won multiple
women I know who have won their husbands
back after that the men have had affairs
and they have wonderful their husbands
are thankful that they didn't you know
divorce them and destroy their family
they wanted they didn't want to destroy
their children's lives because that
destroys children's lives divorce does I
think I saw a tweet I I just started
seeing your tweets a week or two ago but
you said something that divorce should
never happen and I say divorce should
never ever take place between two
Believers in Jesus Christ never ever it
should never happen in anyone unless
there is you know if of the man or the
woman is I know a woman who's completely
physically abusive to her husband
throating throw things at him and beat
him and he had to leave her you know and
in cases on those cases I can completely
see or a man who is an like a one woman
fought for her marriage he he for she he
was having an affair and he loved this
other woman and he ended up moving in
with her and
he found you know
I think he divorced her yeah he told her
he divorced her and you know she let him
go and and she can remarry now because
she was abandoned and he's remarried but
and she fought so it doesn't always work
you know all marriages can't stay
together for those couple of reasons and
sometimes they're just abandoned these
women I know who their husbands just
abandoned them not for an affair or
anything but or the wife multiple men
have mentored my husband's been their
husbands just their wives just abandon
them for no reason just leave them and
um
I'm sorry go ahead no yeah it's just
tragic
yeah well I mean there's exceptions to
every rule right so I wasn't even saying
like there's no exceptions but it's like
okay what we have today isn't marriage
it can't be marriage if the average
marriage is eight years so I was like
you know for the people that believe in
divorce you guys should just stick to
the relationships the living in with
each other so the people that really
don't believe in divorce can do the real
marriage thing because now it's like you
have a whole movement of men that are
going their own way and I actually I
understand it because with the way the
laws are the way they are the women have
so much leverage in a marriage and we
can leave over anything and there's no
guarantees for the guy I know so it's
President Reagan is the one who
instituted no fault divorce which is sad
is sad
I just thought you know and he was we
thought a good president but he also
gave the the um most liberal birth
abortion laws but yeah um
yeah it's it's really sad but you know
like me I I teach truth and everyone
wants me to give the exceptions to
everything submit to your husband
everything you know don't you know stay
married until life to your your part I
just want to teach
you know the rules you guys you're
learning all the exceptions everywhere
else just let's let's let's go with
truth and try to stick with truth you
know thank you thank you
it's like
think about every exception what about
this this and it's just like okay can we
get here
just like I said I've only seen you for
the last two weeks I don't even really
know who you but saying that women who
aren't married should not give marriage
advice and women who don't have children
but you've still
anybody who's lived in this world has
lived around good marriages and bad
marriages you've seen what makes
marriages work what doesn't make
marriages work you've seen what what
child raising practices work which don't
and I don't see why you're completely
disqualified for saying don't get
divorced you know
that's why I'm not giving you a
step-by-step
to your husbands yeah I'm not married
but when I'm married I want to submit to
my husband I probably won't do it
perfectly but I know that it's got to be
the right way you know
I'm my favorite person on the internet
now you have me hold you accountable
once you get married yeah like and this
is the thing I don't pretend to like do
it perfectly but it's just like none of
us yeah and like I'm just I'm not blind
and I see what it does to men that live
their whole lives with like a
quarrelsome wife it's terrible and if I
didn't find this content I like I
probably would do the same thing like
I'm thankful I found this stuff when I'm
26 and not 36. right
so now you're going to start going to a
solid Biblical church and find a Godly
Man huh
yes yes no I wanna
um I'm Catholic so I like I like the
Catholic Church well
I know that I I know some Catholics who
seem to be strong Believers um like Abby
Johnson and Matt Walsh they they speak
more like a True Believer in Jesus
Christ than a lot of Christians they're
reading your Bible talking about Jesus
Christ a lot and um so I know Catholics
who are definitely I don't believe in a
lot of the doctrine of Catholics because
you don't need to go to a priest because
Jesus Christ is our high priest Mary was
just this Fallen sinful
a woman who needed a savior she birthed
the savior of the world you know some of
their doctrines I don't like but I know
I've known Catholics Julios who actually
did read their Bibles study their Bibles
know God's word and um loved the Lord
Jesus Christ very much so just start
reading your Bible start in the Book of
John
read a couple chapters every well no
read Genesis you have to the first three
chapters of Genesis
Foundation of how God created us read
Genesis and then go to John and read to
the end of this Bible a couple chapters
a day and you know find a a Catholic
Church that teaches scripture
if you can find one I just switched my
shows I just I used to be so much better
about going to church until I started
these shows I would do them on Saturday
nights but I just switched it so I could
start go because I went when I was home
this time I was like I missed church I
did when he's gone home I'm moving home
in the fall so I'm moving in with the
parents I'm very excited well still no
well I was until March
so I might do a tournament here or there
but no
um this has to be my last season it was
too much I just can't do it all
yeah get married start having babies
yeah I'm trying I'm trying and then you
can from experience in your experience
as you beca become a wife and mother
and a homemade
I'll still believe it sorry go ahead
I share a lot of my recipes and
homemaking on my Instagram that's where
all my recipes and all my blogs I have a
lot of recipes too so I don't I'm so
busy teaching women
to be submissive and not deprive their
husbands sexually and be chased and
modest and all that with making quiet
spirits that that takes a lot of time
well thank you so much for coming on
um
right now you're one of the most based
women on the internet based just based
thanks
um any where where can the people find
you
um the transform wife I'm on all the
social media platforms as the transform
wife in fact I went on Tick Tock
um several months ago I wasn't gonna go
on Tick Tock but Amanda oh no
they need your voice on Tick Tock so I
have quite a few videos on there I don't
follow anyone I don't do anything on
Tick Tock but make my three little
minute videos then I put them on my
YouTube and someone wrote me I went on
to tick tock and you can't believe how
many people speak wickedly about you and
I go oh really you know at least they're
spreading the truth I don't care if how
the truth is spread like the debt-free
Virgin so many people found me through
that you know and now this mental rape
thing which is so sad
um that I don't do not promote that but
they said you but you know a lot of
people are just seeing truth of what I
teach they don't like it a lot of people
but that's you know truth is not easy
too
it's against what our culture teaches
and believes
I'm like
you know I've been kicked off of there
like five times I know but I you know
what I've already had one
two one one taken they won't allow it
and another one they kept the silence
off but I peeled it and they put the
silence back on it was like I it was
titled a little talk about sex it's like
they're gonna take the sound off that
when what I'm sure they're just plenty
of garbage on tank dog it's like a
little talk about Tick Tock from old
grandma and they're gonna take that off
like I'm gonna do something kinky it's
just like oh brother oh well
they don't like truth no they don't oh
well thank you so much
um guys make sure you like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and go subscribe to her YouTube
um Twitter especially I always I'm
always retweeting her on Twitter like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time